as we are welcoming back super troopers
to our lives we discussed it earlier in
the week with a manual shrieky super
troopers 2 in theaters near you one week
from today Kevin Heffernan part of the
Broken Lizard comedy team good to see
you sir good to see you thanks for
having me you bet what is it like seeing
this back under on the silver screen ah
it's kind of weird you know like a
thousand one was I know I'm rich I want
many many years without a moustache and
then it took me like 15 years to grow
this sucker back I only have 12 hair
holes in my lip so that's as good as I
can do it's it's difficult for me to
grow something out you're doing alright
you got a little scruff focuses that
this is this is months
is it a making am i nearing a full year
with the beard am i close it's been
you've had it for a long time in a while
but for Super Troopers to you know maybe
you can shave the beard and just go for
three we're talking about next week
talking about shaven goats what you got
for the Mustang so how long are you
gonna keep this monster no I think I
think the day after the movie comes out
is gone so in 421 yeah 421 gone I think
so because again I'm an NFL employee I
can't you can't have a mustache no no I
can't well I mean it can the
Commissioner himself has actually given
me grief for having facial oh really
that's actually I it's like the Yankees
rule I've heard for the Yankees rule
that's right you can't go to this you
can go this so now don't go this how old
are you how old are you I am 49 years of
age so we're the same age yes so now Don
Mattingly is a sweet spot right
absolutely
okay yeah before that it's the Reggie
Jackson well I was a Thurman Munson guy
me too I didn't like Reggie by the way I
get teary-eyed when I fall so do I I
have that bill Gallo remember that
cartoon Bilderberg cartoon the
cartoonists of the New York Daily I have
that out of my wall in my office it
makes me cry every time I look at it
about after Thurman passed after he
passed away and they say they don't want
to play baseball today I was in summer
camp when I found out about that where
were you I was going to pee wee football
practice and I was in the car driving
and I heard it on the radio because
that's where you got your news and I got
to the practice I was crying I pulled my
helmet down over my head so my teammates
couldn't see me crying but god I'm
getting I'm getting I'm getting upset
now I did me too you're getting
misty-eyed
Thurman Munson I know yeah so I was a
Munson guy I don't see you every month
you didn't like Reggie hotdogs come on
though Third's drink we know three home
runs against the Dodgers in the World
Series that was it we wouldn't deny that
but you know Munson was the gritty
leader and Jackson was the flashy guy
okay and so Matt but Mattingly is the
guy for a man who's the tragic figure
he's a tragic figure I mean oh you think
well we went from early 80s to 96
whatever was 95 96 right yes one playoff
game and then hit 400 in that playoff
game hit a home run
yeah hit a home run in the playoff
series against the Mariners that ended
with yeah with ken griffey jr. coming
all the way around sliding home I mean
and then they win the World Series next
year 1995 590 right the bull times multi
woman series after he's gone the cap but
the reason why I bring that much shame I
do I know a Red Sox come on come on so
so but your old infest fan you're from
New Haven right oh yeah okay yeah but
that's that's kind of on the mason-dixon
line of Yankee right it is but when I
was growing up West Haven Connecticut
the double a Yankee affiliate was in
West Haven Connecticut and so guys came
through would come through there do you
remember who came through why I remember
well it was a little kid and I read Ron
Guidry 's autobiography and he had a
little paragraph in there and he said
the most dismal and dreary place he ever
played in his life was in West Haven
Connecticut and I was like a
twelve-year-old kid I was like really
Gator and he lived he lived in some
backwater places of he really data and
the worst place ever was my hometown
which was terrible Oh what do you think
of the card team Kevin good I'm a little
scared about the expectations they seem
a little high you know and guys are
always starting getting hurt though
but know that line up you can't you
can't deny that line up so you're Nick
Giants yeah Yankee yeah we were season
ticket holders for the Giants growing up
because of because of Connecticut play
ball for a couple years while they were
building giant Stadium in New Haven my
family got season tickets in that time
and then transferred over to them yeah
we're of the last generation yeah we're
Yankees are usually Giants because they
played in the same stadium right and
Jets are usually mad
because they played in the secular it's
not only the same way I think it's still
not jets magically nothing I kind of you
see more hybrids now yeah it's two
because they used to play in the same
stadium right the same but now it's like
Rams Yankees now it's like you know
people don't care anymore although yeah
all the way all over the map yeah so how
did Super Troopers to come back to being
I don't know there's a lot of we would
go places and people would yell like
quotes at us from the first movie right
and then they'd be like what is the
second one coming out right so for years
it was kind of like this wave of I guess
we got to do it right and so finally we
we kind of put it together but we
couldn't get the studio who owned the
rights to want to make the movie so we
did a crowdfunding thing we did a raised
money on the Internet how much money did
use did you raise five million bucks
from Super Troopers fans yeah yeah
54,000 fans donated five million bucks
that's a month that sounds like a
political campaign it was a lot like
that but it was also dangerous like is
if you put that out there and then
nobody donates then you're done then
you're toast
you have no there's separate troopers
zero then it's over yeah so now people
put the money in and we wouldn't made
the movie for right and so this film is
about you guys are back in the mix yeah
but there's a set-to with with Canada
yeah it's it's topical it's a border war
border politics very very topical very
big right any manual shrieky was here
the other day yeah you noticed Mike Del
2 foot went through some flops well I
saw it and I commiserated with you
because I often flop sweat about Emanuel
sure you have to I mean you know she's
amazing but you're not you're not flop
sweat now I had a good a good makeup get
put on me all right usually you don't
pitting out flops wedding me Tony you
guys don't apply he's in New Jersey I
know there that guy is he a Yankee fan
oh yeah yeah the Red Sox fan is
outnumbered to them Yankee right side
brawl okay so but meeting Lynda Carter
had to be something oh yeah unbelievable
and you know my dad governor your dad
came well my dad's been coming on the
sets and the only person who's really
excited about it was Lynda Carter and so
we called her back to come for the
second movie and for some reason my
parents found themselves eating dinner
in the hotel restaurant with Lynda
Carter hold on a second yeah
this is what I see what we were shooting
the second thing and she was shooting we
were all staying the same hotel we're
outside of Boston yeah
my parents were there visiting the set
they're sitting in the hotel restaurant
and Lynda Carter sits down with them
because you know we kind of know each
other okay
and my dad's sitting there and Lynda
Carter he's having a burger and fries
and Lynda Carter reaches onto his plate
and takes one of his french fries and
you know each one his french fries and
he got flustered he blushed it he flops
what he flops sweating a little bit
because Lynda Carter
ate a french fry off his plate he was he
was so excited about it so mmm I mean
you can imagine if Wonder Woman decided
to help herself with some fries we have
a special place in our you know our age
guys you know it's wonder wonder wonder
woman yeah and so now I've done four
movies with her now we're buddies now
which is amazing it is amazing how this
is all working out Rob Lowe is in it as
well Brian Cox
yeah coxy he's a no offense I mean this
is a real thespian I know he did
Shakespeare in Moscow that guy I mean
that's how that's how good he is you
know that is the height of is that would
you set what he says I would say you
know Broadway like Broadway's kind of
the height of that profession it's true
Shakespearean in Moscow well that he
said that one night we were shooting the
first Super Troopers and it was a night
shoot and it was some crazy stuff we
were doing and we were laughing and
making mom jokes or whatever as we do
and I remember him sitting in the
backseat of the police car just looking
out the window whistling wistfully you
know and he's like I did Shakespeare in
Moscow whatever happened to craft but
now he look you know he says that's this
is the most recognized he gets of any
movies done the x-men movies the born
everything yeah Super Troopers is the
thing that people quote and well
congrats on on your getting the gang
back to you thank you you got it thank
you
it is in theaters coming up a week from
Friday any other way being an NFL
employee I cannot say 4/20 oh really no
I'm just I'm just I'm just trying to be
smart about sure I guess so it's opening
up it's opening up on April 20th one
week from today
and eight days before Kevin Heffernan
will shave off his mustache there you go
boom there you go that's what we are
right now thanks for coming on thank you
Richard thank God it check him out at
Heffernan rules on Twitter Super
Troopers 2 in theaters near you in a
week the Rich Eisen show week
at noon eastern on audience